[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Mike
joins us in Washington DC up next Mike
welcome to the show hey guys thanks uh
hope you're doing well today absolutely
what's going on with you well I have an
88y old mother who's getting ready to
run out of money um like really run out
of money but let me give you a
background here uh my dad passed away 15
years ago and he left her the 15 acre
property that that they were living in
and she stayed there uh the house is now
say neglected certainly dated needs some
work it's about 45 minutes away from me
and where my brother lived but in 2020
she had a little issu she''s been having
some medical issues she nearly burned
the house down had some issues like that
so my brother and his wife convinced her
to live in a nearby retirement home and
I wasn't included in that process she
didn't want to move but she agreed and
she's been there since August of 2021
and been paying the mortgage on the
house and she'd been paying for the
retirement home and that's about bone
rate of about 10,000 a month um I don't
know all of her finances I I I ask her
questions and she gets irritated uh my
brother's kind of handling that but
without a power of attorney or anything
um I basic I have to steal some of her
mail and and look at it figure out and
what I got down to is that in her family
trust all the money my dad left and her
parents left her and everything there's
about $3,000 in cash left in that
and about uh maybe 30,000 um in stocks
and I think about 15 in a checking
account that's it have you not called
your brother and
just said what in the world are you
doing how does that conversation go uh
it usually goes with I'm working on it
um he wants to make sure the house is
perfect before it sells which it'll
never happen that that's one thing I've
asked you know what's going on with the
finances I'll get back to you uh oh
there's a plan I I'll tell you but I've
never been told how how dude I'm being
honest like I've got I've got a brother
he's he's got such he's a person of such
impeccable character this wouldn't this
wouldn't never apply
but I would I would be really close if I
were you to in fact not really close I
would probably draft a letter from an
attorney because a something sounds
fishy here B I don't care what plan your
brother has your mother's about to lose
everything yeah everything and it's it's
it's time to stop waiting for a plan one
of the problems here and I'm sure
something you've probably heard of like
she's come out and said in the past she
likes him better she as a person and
everything else now that aside uh she
every time I ask about something oh I
trust him I I used to take her to the
doctor and I would take her shopping I
don't even get that that anymore so I'm
so far out of the loop um on this
because I think ultimately I'm the
realist and I'm the one who who has to
um I'm the one who tells her what she
needs and he's the one who does what she
wants and that's part of the problem why
this house is sitting on the market for
it's not even on market for two years it
hasn't even been on the market yet in
two years um but yeah
it's do you think he has some kind of
vested interest where he's driving this
wedge between you guys on purpose and he
stands to gain
something no I think he's just pretty
much kind of like just a just a dum dum
and he has always had issues uh let see
type issu but also just uh he can't make
a decision those sorts of things he's
the older brother I'm the younger
brother yeah but nobody nobody's that
dumb to where there's $240,000 in an
account and two years later at a burn
rate of 10 grand a month there's three
everybody knows this this train stops
next
month yeah and it it actually when it
stops it's going to park itself in his
house so yeah there's nowhere else for
to go now she says she's gonna get a
camper and take her cat and of course
she says that that's not happening of
course of course but so here's the deal
it sounds like there's two things one is
there's the money aspect of
it but I'm more interested
in you are watching your mom a woman you
love and who loved
you slowly peel away and head in a
direction that you don't believe is
healthy and I think what you've just
played out for is it's not healthy and
you're
heartbroken yeah there there's really
it's kind of the one of the reasons I
call it was kind of a precautionary tale
for others who you know you think you
have a plan her plan was to die and I
know that's a fact she planned to die at
that house and all this would be taken
care of of course of course um and I
think she's still counting on that now
like oh it's not gonna be a problem
because I'll be dead and it's GNA go
away what if she lives another decade
well yeah she says she's gonna live to
be 100 and then the other hand you know
well do some quick math with her and
show her that she's out of money in a
year I'm I'm more worried that there's
way more money in this trust than your
brother's done something nefarious with
it he's either so in so listen to this
the options here he is so incredibly
incompetent that his incompetence is so
bad his mother's going to end up
homeless or he's had some Financial
incentive to keep you out of the
books well she refinanced this house 10
years ago now she's been in it for 30 so
she would have paid it off um my dad had
sold our old house when they moved out
to this other place so there's 300,000
that was put into it into a $500,000
like it would have been paid off
somebody somewhere about 10 years ago
got her to refinance and about 10 years
ago my brother was $20,000 in debt and
then suddenly bought a house so sure I'm
I'm kind of thinking that's where that
money went but nobody wants to tell me
and that's why she gets irritated and he
won't answer the questions and I think
they refinanced she took the pulled out
the equity he for here's the deal
brother here's the deal man you
can wipe your hands of this and grieve
like bloody hell your
mom yeah and your relationship and it
shouldn't be this way and you wish you
were still one of her boys and she has
chosen the other one she's told you I
choose him over you I cannot wrap my
head around how devastating that would
be if my mom did that you know what it's
actually um more than devast it's
actually a relief okay because now I
know I I know why things are happening
the way they are okay it it might be a
relief in the short
term but you're gonna have to grieve
that or the second thing is you get an
attorney and demand Financial
Accounting quite honestly you're gonna
have to sue your brother probably and if
she made him the the heir of this stuff
it your suit probably won't even matter
yeah he's the executive but not the
power of attorney who's the power of
attorney
nobody she she still retains everything
okay well this is bordering on Elder
Financial abuse and so that makes me
think we need to get some third parties
involved to look into this before we
continue to destroy her life yeah those
are the words I was looking for because
that's what I was thinking but you've
kind of I mean I'm no lawyer but I would
contact one immediately and just explain
the
situation and here's what's hard she
might talk to an attorney and say I have
directed my oldest son to do every
single thing I want when I run out of
money I'm going to move in with him or
I'll move back into my magic
home both of those are options on the
table for her uhhuh she said so the
bottom line is an 88-year-old woman
should not have $10,000 in expenses
every single
month no especially with a burn rate
with with a Finish Line coming up real
tell me her expenses aren't 10 that
money is going somewhere and it sounds
like it's going partially to your
brother so I'm sorry you're dealing with
this mik this is a a tangled web of just
broken relationships and financial abuse
and uh I hope you find some resolution
even if it's not the one you're looking
for create your free every dooll budget
today the simplest way to budget for
your life